bullying is one of the major issues that
is that have always been discussed in
the discussion in the education reform
conversation and and the debate and a
lot of people think when they talk about
bullying is that if we can just solve it
by kind of teaching kids to be kinder
for another or implementing these kind
of anti-bullying programs where these
ruthless punishments if somebody's seen
bullying somebody but when you talk
about these issues of bullying a lot of
people fail to understand the role of
the institution and perpetuate issues
such as bullying and Peter Gray for
example a psychologist Boston Boston
College has written about bullying and
and and looked at prisons and and
schools and the effects of bullying on
those institutions and what he says is
that when when when there's a population
of people who are be were being held in
an institution where they have no
freedom to quit or ability to get
escaped from that place where they have
very little ownership or voice and
control over what happens in that
institution incidents such as bullying
are rampant and in schools it's very
clear I mean the the statistics show
that bullying is a major major problem
in most American schools and what they
find is that in school schools have a
number of different qualities and one of
them is the anti-democratic governing
structure if you look at most American
high schools for example they are
gargantuan mammoth institutions they
have thousands upon thousands of kids
walking through the hallways every day
and what what happens as a result of
this and this is not necessarily the
fault of teachers or even just the
people in that school building when you
have such a large student body and you
don't have you have large class sizes
there's not enough time for students and
teachers to have really strong authentic
and genuine relationships and students
basically what happens is they get kind
of thrown into this the see of being
anonymous they don't they don't have any
relationships with their their students
with their fellow peers and and students
that are really rich an authentic level
and so when students feel that they have
no power or no agency
their school experiences what often
happens is something called cliques
arise if students feel that they have
two real power and get control within
themselves and within their ranks and so
cliques are one of the major phenomenons
in American schools where they create
basically power structures within the
student body themselves and so you have
people at the top of the system who are
essentially the most popular kids they
and then you have the kids at the bottom
or oftentimes the the Nerds and the
people who are not so that's a popular
to have the best looks and so you have
this very destructive system that comes
about and bullying is one of the side
effects and symptoms that come out of
that and so what I would argue is that
when you have institutions that where
students and teachers have strong
relationships with one another where
students feel that they are known by the
adult in that community where they have
agency and voice over the learning
experiences bullying incidents are very
rare and in my book I talk about
institutions and three schools and
democratic schools where bullying is
almost non-existent and this is a large
part due to the fact that students feel
that they have a voice and role in their
school decision-making process and they
have the structures in place to fix and
alleviate incidents of bullying so if
everything is transparent where they can
bring it to an adult or the school
community and show that this individual
is bullying me and we need to rectify
the situation and not only that they
have restorative justice practices so
instead of just as suspending the kid or
engaging you're kind of zero-tolerance
policy they'll go through a process of
healing and and the restorative justice
to make sure that the individual who has
been harmed as well as the individual
who are perpetrated the act understands
the the the incident and works to
alleviate the situation in the future so
it's a much better process of healing
and restoration as opposed to just
suspending the kid and leaving them out
and nothing gets solved and it's kind of
this trying to patch a bullet with a
band-aid it doesn't actually solve the
underlying problem